today on the matt wall show teachers in
philadelphia were encouraged to attend
an outrageously graphic and perverse sex
workshop you have to hear some of these
details to believe them also congress
held the first public hearings on ufos
in over 50 years yesterday but much to
my great shock dismay and despair
nobody seems to care you jerks plus we
analyzed the election results from last
night to see what we can learn from them
and marvel announces its new feminist
female hulk plus in our daily
cancellation a sports writer complains
that black athletes are the victims of
white supremacy because white fans pay
money
to watch them play we'll try to make
sense of that though it's impossible and
so much more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
well i don't have to tell you that uh
gas prices are insanely high right now
and i think the latest is that they're
officially over four dollars a gallon in
every single state in the country and uh
in many places there are quite a bit
more
you're looking at quite a bit more than
four dollars a gallon well here's good
news um there is an incredible app
everyone who buys gas needs to know
about especially now it's called upside
my listeners are earning cash back for
every gallon of gas every time you fill
up just download the free upside app in
the app store or google play right now
use promo code walsh for 25
or rather 25 cents per gallon or more on
your first fill up and that's all that
you get cash back it's that simple don't
pay full price of the pump anymore get
cash back using upside just download the
app for free and use promo code walsh
for 25 cents per gallon or more on your
first tank and it's not just for gas you
can earn cash back at grocery stores
restaurants and with takeout too you can
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands all you gotta do is
download the free upside app and use
promo code walsh to get 25 cents per
gallon or more cash back on your first
tank it's you got to do this we're all
looking to save money especially on gas
so do it right now just use my promo
code walsh now that's codewalsh at the
upside app we know that many teachers in
this country are groomers but the
question about groomers that isn't asked
often enough is who grooms the groomers
in order for teachers to groom children
effectively they must first themselves
be groomed and this means that those of
us who wish to uncover expose and put an
end to the grooming epidemic in public
schools have to dig a little bit deeper
to answer this question
see where it starts because if we simply
call out the predator teachers then
we're just pruning the branches of this
giant hideous tree we're not getting to
the roots that's what brings us to the
latest expose from journalist chris rufo
who alerts us to a recent conference
advertised to and attended by
teachers in the philadelphia school
district
the conference as roofo reveals
covers such topics as kink bdsm trans
sex and quote
banging beyond binaries
oh and the conference was open to
children as well roofo reports quote in
early july 2021 the district office of
diversity equity inclusion sent
invitations to the philadelphia trans
wellness conference to teachers and
staff on the sdb sdp connect mailing
list promoting the conference as a way
to quote learn more about the issues
facing the trans community the
conference was organized by the mazzoni
center an lgbtq
activist organization that has worked
with the district on sexual education
programs when reached for comment the
school district of philadelphia
described his promotion of the
conference as part of its commitment to
creating equitable and inclusive
environments and said that it did not
have any information on the number of
teachers who attended the event sure
they didn't
now we have some video from this
conference that we're going to play for
you
much of it cannot be played because it's
so relentlessly graphic that i'd have to
bleep pretty much the whole clip but
before we play them you need to realize
that this non-profit the mizoni center
um it is uh it's influential well-funded
entirely within the mainstream of the
modern left
and speaking of its funding last year it
received five million dollars in
government contracts
that is according to its own financial
disclosures by far and away its greatest
single source of income it only made
about two to three hundred thousand
dollars in donations another 150 grand
in grants and then 2 million from the
paycheck protection program
so this is an organization
propped up and funded by the government
and used to indoctrinate government
employees who then turn around and
indoctrinate our children and also as
reference the mizoni center they create
sex education programs which are then
used in schools
so what are they all about i mean what
do they teach
for that we turn to some of this footage
which is i warn you
extremely disturbing and gross
but also important that we see some of
this and we start with a seminar with a
trans activist talking about prosthetic
penises and quote masturbation sleeves
let's watch
the purpose of this workshop is to
showcase different types of prosthetics
available for sex
almost every single one that i will be
showing you all of them actually look
like penises
i have tried and touched many
all right prosthetics real
all
this is one of the most realistic
feeling in terms of like the inside of a
penis all right now a pack and play is
going to be a prosthetic that you can
use for sex but you can also pack with
it when you're not having sex you're
just walking around it's your everyday
packer that you just wear in your pants
and then when you're ready to get in the
mood you're boy yoyoing and you can go
and have sex
but here
that it's a big boy this is like
gigantic all right give me
give me two hours alone and i'll get
this in my butt you know
that's a
government-funded
workshop
for teachers
a government-funded workshop
for teachers
now why would teachers need to know
about dildos and prosthetic penises
in order to do their job teaching
children the groomer claim is a
homophobic conspiracy theory we're told
if that's the case then why is the
philadelphia school district
suggesting that his teachers attend a
deviant sex work workshop
there's a whole grooming thing it's not
happening
this is everything you're seeing right
here none of this is happening it's not
actually happening
it's just your imagination
another class was titled transects
banging beyond binaries and here's how
the host and leader of that session
introduced
i think it's herself
impossible to tell anymore but
introduced herself
and i'm also um a pretty big
i'm a and i and i i wear that title
pretty proudly um
and i i self-identify as kinky and
polyamorous
and
um
and i also call myself an organizer
because in my free time outside of my
day job i like to get people together to
explore
their fantasies and
their perversions in groups
hi i'm lucy fielding and my pronouns are
she they please mix them with reckless
abandon
i am a resident in counseling in
practicing in charlottesville virginia
i am also a sex educator and um i'm a
white
queer
kinky polyamorous
um
visibly able-bodied
jewish witchy
non-binary trans-fem
now it's difficult to select just one
thing for this distinction but perhaps
the most disturbing part of that clip
is that the self-described white queer
kinky polyamorous visibly able-bodied
because that needs to be added now to
your
list of identities jewish witchy
non-binary trans femme is a counselor
and that's not a quirk or a coincidence
by the way the counseling industry seeks
these types out
which is why the entire field must be
i'm afraid to say distrusted and
discounted
by the way later in the same session
they shared some thoughts about more
inclusive terms for body parts that the
teachers could learn and of course bring
into their classrooms
so let's uh let's hear some of those
suggestions
so this is how the game's going to work
is that we're going to drop into the
chat different words that we like to
hear
for
bodies um that are not gendered that are
like completely
just
fun names
for
people's bodies
like
a great one just as an example just to
get it going and then you all can
jump into the chat is um
i like
people to use the word
goodies
can i touch your goodies
i feel your goodies
thank you to sierra
that
that was uh introduced to me back in
middle school
yeah
chest and front and back hole are great
too
front and back hole um quite a romantic
way to speak i'm sure that'll get people
in the mood
and there's much more footage along
these lines and worse as roofo reports
the conference began with presentations
promoting puberty blockers hormone
treatments breast removals and genital
surgeries in one session which was
titled the adolescent pathway preparing
young people for gender affirming care
by dr scott mosser
the principal at the gender confirmation
center in san francisco explained that
he has performed over 2 000 top
surgeries which which involve removing
girl's breasts that there's no age limit
for beginning the gender journey quote i
do not have a minimum age of any sort in
my practice
he said explaining that he would be
willing to consult with children as
young as 10 years old with parental
consent
in another session open to children
gender affirming masculine and
feminizing hormones for adolescents and
adults dane menken divisional director
of lgbtq services at mainline health
endorsed treatments ranging from puberty
blocking hormones to manual breast
binding for masculinizing adolescent
girls he said quote i'm a strong
proponent that you can bind for as many
hours a day as you can tolerate binding
now all this is horrifying of course
especially ten-year-old
ten-year-old girls
at his practice where he chops breasts
off of
girls he would he would accept a uh
a quote patient as young as 10.
now all of this of course would have
been considered far far left obscure
crazy fringe stuff
only just a decade ago or less
now it's being taught to teachers in
philadelphia at government-funded
workshops
and everything said by these people is
obviously disturbing disgusting and
morally debased but i would like to
focus on just on just one statement made
in the first clip that we played
the woman as you recall
embraces the term perversion
okay it's the term she uses
she openly says that she encourages
people to explore their quote
perversions
now this is a very important choice of
words because the word perversion
literally means
corruption that's what the word means
when something is perverted it is by
definition being taken off of its
original course it's being distorted or
corrupted taken away from what was first
intended for it
this is the dictionary definition of the
term perversion
and that's what this is all about
that's what this conference is intended
to do corrupt the teachers so that they
may corrupt the students
when we talk about children being
groomed what we actually mean is that
they're being corrupted
this is in fact the left's entire sexual
agenda in a nutshell so to speak and
because it's their entire sexual agenda
it's also their entire agenda period
their whole their whole world view
revolves around sex they see nothing but
sex everything comes back to sex there's
no removing sex from education as far as
they're concerned because they cannot
remove sex from anything that's why when
you say this well why can't you just
educate the kids without all this sex
stuff it does it doesn't even compute
they cannot perceive
um anything outside of sex
everything comes back to that for them
these are the ideological progeny of
alfred kinsey after all and he was a
psychotic deviant who said that everyone
else was a psychotic deviant just like
him and he believed that everyone was
sexual from birth and that everything
was sexual that there was no way to
separate sex from anything
his disciples believe the same
but their sexual agenda just like their
agenda in every other area of life
it doesn't seek to to build or or create
anything new
it doesn't even we talk about how they
want to normalize this or that and
that's i i think that's not exactly
the right word
because they actually want a world where
nothing is normal there is just the
concept of normalcy doesn't exist
what leftism seeks to do is destroy
simply
and leave the ruins to sit there and
decay
and it does this in a very literal sense
to human bodies it chops the breasts off
of girls and leaves them to live with
the scars mutilated and broken
how will this help them how will it make
them happier
what are they supposed to do now i mean
you chop their breasts off you take a
ten year old girl
and mutilate her what's she supposed to
do now
well nothing doesn't matter to the left
all they want is to to take everything
that is whole and true and natural and
normal
and just blow it to smithereens
it is a movement of destruction
especially sexual destruction
so yeah they want to groom your kids
but they're grooming them for
annihilation
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know what you need as we head into
the summer you you don't need a swimsuit
especially because it's it's that's
that's a waste of time what you need are
new burgers i'm talking about american
wagyu burgers from good ranchers the
best burgers you'll ever try you get two
pounds of your new favorite burger for
free with my code walsh what is american
wagyu which i think i'm pronouncing
correctly it's some of the best beef
you'll ever try it's as simple as that
good ranchers american wagyu is raised
here in the states and produces the rich
and buttery wagyu texture that people
crave their american wagyu burgers take
everything to a whole new level of
delicious and uh they're just extremely
good you don't have you don't have to
just use them for burgers this ground
american wagyu is versatile and elevates
any meal to a whole new level you could
use them to make tacos stir fry you
could and i have used them for this by
the way
to make meatballs as well i use good
ranchers wagyu burgers and my famous
chili as well for instance this is a
limited time offer so don't miss out on
our two pounds of free american wagyu
place your order today remember to
subscribe and save 25 on every box of
100 american meat from good ranchers two
pounds of free wagyu burgers and zero
inflation what are you waiting for use
my code walsh or visit goodranchers.com
walsh if you don't buy the meat in your
house then tell the person who does to
grab your two pounds of free american
wagyu burgers today before they're gone
that's promo code wallshoot
goodranchers.com
walsh
i'm going to start with this headline
and i have to tell you i am
uh i'm upset
okay and i admit that well you know what
i'm not upset i'm disappointed
i am disappointed
i'm disappointed in all of you
not the sweet baby gang because i know
that you're with me on this you must be
to be in the cult but everybody else the
rest of you i'm disappointed because
there was
a congressional hearing
on ufos yesterday
televised okay first time in like 50
years
it's a televised hearing on ufos
and nobody cared
like i i went on twitter because i knew
they were they were kind of i was doing
the show and they were doing the hearing
and i was like afterwards i was i was
going to go and i was excited to go on
social media i thought everyone will be
talking about ufos no one's talking
about it nobody cares
they're showing videos
of ufos a government officials at at a
congressional hearing on tv saying
here's some ufos we found look at that
and everyone's just like yawning
you know it's just ufos
they said they're investigating 400 ufo
sightings
they've only explained one of them
that's 399 unexplained ufos nobody cares
you know what you guys are all talking
about you talk about johnny depp and
amber heard instead
okay they're we're in the middle of an
alien invasion here and everyone's like
yeah but you ever heard about the latest
with the amber heard trial
the aliens could actually land here on
earth and get out of their spaceships
and we would still be talking about
johnny depp and amber herr maybe we
would ask them when they get did you
guys have you guys heard about that
johnny depp thing what's your take on
that
so but no you'll talk about
those mutant freaks johnny depp and
amber heard what about the mutant freaks
who are flying in spaceships in the sky
it's just
highly disappointing
literally
the government's admitting that we're
being invaded by aliens maybe not
literally okay that's how i choose to
interpret it living my truth but they
are but it is pretty extraordinary it
doesn't happen every day
i mean we went my almost my entire adult
life it's like nobody in the government
would talk about the ufo thing
so there'll be no discussion about it at
all and now they're out
in the open talking about it
and nobody cares there was a little bit
of media coverage on it so i want to
play uh whether you care about this or
not you're still going to be subjected
to it so here's the the abc report it
gives us a good little summary of this
incredible
hearing which is major news whether
people realize it or not let's watch
this
it was moments like these challenging
the limits of physics that raised
potential security risks that were too
big to ignore my gosh
against the wind the wind's 120 west the
military releasing this 2015 video two
years ago showing naval pilots off the
coast of california completely stunned
we were seeing them nearly every day
that we were flying today for the first
time since the 1960s members of the
house intelligence subcommittee and top
pentagon officials discussing the topic
of ufos now referred to as uaps or
unidentified aerial phenomenon we are
committed to a focused effort to
determine their origins in 2004 the
pentagon acknowledged tracking more than
140 reports of uaps but today deputy
director for naval intelligence scott
bray says efforts to encourage pilots to
report mysterious encounters has swelled
the number they're investigating to
approximately 400. last year a
government report found a definitive
explanation for only one of the
encounters bray says one video was a
distortion stemming from light passing
through night vision goggles as for a
second video showing a shiny spherical
object i do not have an explanation for
what this
this specific
object is bray confirmed that the
military has never fired missiles at a
ufo or recovered any non-terrestrial
wreckage still the pentagon says it's
determined to remove the stigma
associated with reporting sightings the
inability to understand objects in our
sensitive
operating areas is tantamount to an
intelligence failure unidentified aerial
phenomena are a potential national
security threat
fascinating
it is fascinating and you should be
fascinated by it and i'll yell at you
until you agree with me that this is
interesting
this is the you know all the uh
sci-fi films and and books and
everything
through all through the years this is
what they all got wrong like predicting
what would happen
if aliens if if the existence of aliens
was ever confirmed if aliens ever came
here
and uh you know usually it's like
apocalyptic there's panic people running
in the streets i mean all kinds of
different different things
what what none of the sci-fi writers
bargain for is that uh the reaction
would be just
like a shrug nobody would care
so it's like you watch independence day
and the giant
ufo spaceship is hovering over the
entire
the you know entire cities
of course in that film people are
looking up they're shocked you know
they're getting out of their cars on the
highway and looking
what nobody realized is that in reality
people would just go about their days
you know what you
people would be more interested
if rather than information about actual
ufos
there was a movie about it like
if yesterday instead they had just
announced that there's a new star wars
film
that would interest people a lot more
people are more interested in in fake
stories about aliens
than in the reality of them
blows my mind
how does this not interest you there's
it's all there's a whole universe out
there it could be other
billions of other intelligent
civilizations who knows if they've come
here maybe they have
they're trying to make contact with us
and we don't care because we're talking
about johnny depp and amber heard
i saw a lot of takes like this yesterday
from jim jordan
uh he says
five dollar gas no baby formula record
crime record inflation border crisis
and what's congress doing today holding
a hearing on ufos
well yeah
it's like the one worthwhile thing
congress has done in years
it's certainly the one interesting thing
it's the oh this is the only interesting
thing that has happened in washington dc
in decades
i'm disappointed
all right let's uh go to less
interesting political news this is from
the daily wire says representative
madison cawthorne
conceded his bid for re-election on
tuesday losing the republican primary to
gop state senator chuck edwards
hawthorne's campaign was buffeted in
recent weeks by a number of leaks about
his personal behavior prior to holding
office including the leak of a nude
video
cartharon called edwards to concede
defeat late tuesday after results showed
him trailing by about two points with
almost all precincts reporting now
um
madison cawthorne obviously had all the
name recognition he had the trump
endorsement
um i believe he did yeah he had the
trump endorsement he
had a lot more money his fundraising
efforts were going he's raising a whole
lot more money than his competitor and
he still ends up losing because
in the last few weeks there was this
full-on assault
and not just from the left but from the
right from the republican party
to destroy this guy and and kick him out
of office and they succeeded
and i'm not the first person to draw
this connection where it's a very it's
kind of an interesting thing that all of
this started for madison carthorn
all of the start almost immediately
after he was we played the clip on this
show several weeks ago when he was on a
podcast and he made the claim that uh
some people in congress engage in
drug-fueled orgies you know
and we played that clip but i laughed
about it a little bit just because the
way he phrased it he said that he had
been invited to i don't remember the
exact phrasing i think he said that he
had been invited to sexual get togethers
and i just you know i i don't know
what someone says when they're inviting
you to a drug fueled orgy because i've
never been invited to one but i assume
that's probably not what they say so you
can kind of laugh about that but
the claim
that some people in washington are
involved in activity like this well like
clearly that that does happen
that's actually not shocking at all but
as soon as he said this
that's when it all went to hell for him
which would seem to
maybe confirm the claims that he was
making because otherwise
and this is something
again from the republican party trying
to destroy him
and there are other republicans in the
party that the establishment doesn't
like
uh marjorie taylor greene
lauren bobert you know those those kinds
and they're all kind of ideologically in
the same camp with madison cawthorne and
yeah they don't like
marjory telegram they're not doing
anything like this to her though not
anywhere to this extent
where with madison cartham they they
tried to and succeeded in completely
ripping him apart and destroying him
and if the the claim that he made about
the drug-fueled orgies if it was
completely off the wall ridiculous
doesn't happen
then you'd think they would just laugh
it off and ignore it it's not like he
named names he didn't say anybody
and so if it's totally ridiculous and it
doesn't happen
then why wouldn't they just say oh
that's that's that's dumb that's that's
that's stupid that's and laugh about it
because it's it's ridiculous
well it it would seem like um
he was talking about things they didn't
want him to talk about
i don't think you have to be a
conspiracy theorist
to uh come to that conclusion
or maybe it is a maybe it is a theory of
of about something of a conspiracy and
and that's you know that's fine because
actually in real life there are
conspiracies that that do in fact happen
people can conspire to do things and
there's no question at all that there
were people conspiring to get rid of
madison
cawthor and the question is why why all
of a sudden do they have to get rid of
him and why did they go about it with
this kind of ruthlessness and intensity
that they've never
applied to anyone else even people
similar to him ideologically
also from the daily watches the
republican primary race for
pennsylvania's open u.s senate seat was
too close to call as of early wednesday
morning uh television host dr mamet oz
and former treasurer department official
david mccormick had each secured
slightly above 31 of the republican
electorate with over 95 votes tally
conservative commentator kathy barnett
had earned slightly below 25 just so
she's she's out and now it's between
mccormick and oz and uh there's going to
be a recount because it was within the
margin that automatically triggers the
recount
you know what i'll say is um
first of all it's it's quite clear given
how close this is
that if oz
did not get the trump endorsement
you know he would lose i mean i think
the trump endorsement we could we could
agree is worth at least point five
percent in in in the in the polls
probably a lot more than that
so if trump had not endorsed oz he would
not be winning right now or would not be
in a position to potentially win right
now
and it wasn't just uh trump that
endorsed him
sean hannity
he had a lot of uh
high-profile republicans coming out for
him in a big way
and also giving kathy barnett a little
bit of the madison cawthorn treatment
trying to completely destroy her
which again politically they succeeded
in that too
but meanwhile dr oz i must
repeatedly remind you
is a pro-abortion
gun-grabbing
blm supporting
leftist
who also happens to be um a
a turkish dual citizen
running for senate in pennsylvania but
he doesn't live there
and
he supports uh transgender surgeries for
minors
doesn't just support it but was one of
the one of the earliest
promoters of this kind of thing he was
promoting it back in 2011.
and this is the guy that we're going to
end up with i'll tell you this if i
lived in pennsylvania still
and it was dr oz versus a democrat i
would not vote
because what's the difference
you explain to me the difference
ideologically between dr oz and a
democrat
they hold precisely identical views on
every
important topic
now it's just a question of do we want
to reward
guys like dr oz by voting for him
the people who endorsed him and put him
in this position do we want to reward
them
by voting for him
well i'm not in pennsylvania so i have
no say over that but if i was in
pennsylvania i tell you right now i
certainly wouldn't vote for a democrat i
would never vote for a democrat but i'm
not voting at all because there's no
option it's two democrats it is two far
left democrats
it's this is not even a lesser of two
evils thing i don't think there's any
way really to distinguish between them
anything i mean you could you could make
the argument and it wouldn't be that
far-fetched that the republican in this
race now if it is dr oz will be farther
to the left than the democrat
the democrat candidate was he pushing
transgender surgeries back 10 years ago
probably not
so you could very easily argue that dr
oz is farther to the left than the
democrat he's running
against great endorsements
um tom elliott at grabian media has a
great super cut for us you know we've
been of course ensured that the claim
that the white demographic is shrinking
and being replaced by other demographics
is a racist conspiracy theory so let's
see
who exactly is spreading that theory
let's play a little bit of this
compilation in a few years we're going
to be a majority brown country white
people will not be the majority in the
country anymore this will be the first
generation ever in american history
uh in which whites will be a minority of
the generation at some point as of 2007
every year babies being born in this
country whites now with a minority in
2044
everyone is going to be a minority as
the demographics change as white people
become the minority in the country which
is coming demographics is destiny
demographics is destiny demographics is
destiny right the country is changing
i've been saying it here other people
been saying it here for years now even
before donald trump the demographics
is destiny the white population is
declining for the first time in history
in america while the number of
multi-racial americans
have more than doubled so we live in a
country where the demographics are
changing it's becoming less white
correct okay you'll be announcing that
we're calling the 38 electoral votes of
texas for the democratic nominee for
president it's changing it's going to
become a purple state and then a blue
state because of the demographics
because of the population growth the
growth in texas has been almost entirely
driven by non-white population growth
mostly by hispanic and latino population
growth the idea that
uh you know whites will will not be the
majority
i mean that's it's an exciting
transformation of the country it's an
exciting evolution and you know progress
of our country in many different ways
the white population is declining
it was always on the upswing so that
speaks to the beautiful diversity of
america
uh the white temple the white
demographic is declining we heard from
of course there's nothing but democrats
and leftist media saying that white
demographic is declining and that's
exciting and beautiful they say
which by the way if you want to try to
make excuses for this and say oh no well
they're just celebrating diversity or
whatever um no what what they are
specifically it's one thing if they're
saying well there are um
there are there's a there are more black
people there are more hispanics that's
not even what they're saying they are
specifically
celebrating the decline
in a certain racial demographic
that's what they're happy about
so it's clear that the white demographic
is indeed declining
that's just those those that's just what
the data says everyone agrees there
the two remaining questions are whether
the left is happy about it
and whether they're facilitating this
shift
you know doing it intentionally
well are they happy about it
we just heard there it's exciting it's
beautiful we played some clips yesterday
on the show so no question about that of
course they're happy about it
they're happy about it for a lot of
reasons and one of them as we heard in
the clips is that it helps them
politically
as the demographics shift it turns red
states purple and then and then blue
and then the next question is whether
they're facilitating are they trying
intentionally to facilitate
this demographic change
given that we know the demographic
change is happening they say it
themselves we just played the clips we
know they're happy about it again they
say it themselves we just played the
clips are they facilitating it are they
are they
trying to
bring about this result or help it along
in some way
well
um
when you throw open
the borders
actually a throat there's nothing to
throw open because of most of these
places there's nothing you know there's
no door to throw open but so when you
just invite an unchecked flood of
illegals into the country
i would say you're facilitating it
and you're doing it because you know it
will help you politically
they they want to turn texas purple and
then blue
and how do you do that you bring in a
lot of illegals
and it's not just illegal immigration
either they're also increasingly
excluding uh whites from institutions
yet affirmative action policies in place
which specifically state okay we need to
have fewer white people accepted
uh we want to we want to minimize the
number of white people in this
institution or in positions of power
these are actual policies they have in
place
so everything you you can put whatever
label you want on what we're talking
about here
but one thing you can't call it
is a theory it's not a theory it is
happening
and if you listen to it to them they'll
openly admit it all right one other
thing i want to play for you
a little bit of a lighter note
uh media is very excited the
entertainment media very excited today
because it's it's been announced there's
a marvel has a new show coming out uh
she-hulk and so this is kind of like the
feminist female hulk
and it's getting rave reactions in the
media the trailer just came out i want
to play a little bit of the trailer by
the way this is real this is not like a
parody or something this is not a
babylon b thing this is an actual show
that they're putting together they're
gonna put out there she-hulk let's uh
let's watch a little bit of this
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
[Music]
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
if you have not seen the movie idiocracy
uh you really should see it's the most
prophetic film possibly
in the history of cinema
and we are living that that every that
that right there is like a fake it's
like a fake film that you would see in
the film idiocracy
that's what that is
and but people will watch it you know
you know something else i watch these
trailers i don't watch any of the actual
uh shows or marvel movies
because i'm an adult number one
uh and i have self-respect
but when i see the trailers
one of the things that really jumps out
of me is uh on top of just how stupid it
all is and all the wokeness and
everything now we got a female feminist
hulk who's literally sweeping men off
their feet and everything
but also this is it just me or has the
cgi the computer graphics are worse
like if if i didn't know any better and
you showed me that trailer and you said
that that was a show from 1992 i would
believe you based on how it looks
so is this just my imagination or have
the special effects somehow gotten worse
in fact you can i might not believe that
it was from the 90s because it doesn't
look good enough to be in the 90s
the special effects in the 90s were
better
go back and watch the original jurassic
park
that the special effects of that movie
are still kind of stunning because it's
better than anything you see in movies
today
so that's the one thing at least we know
that um
that
uh very rarely are our good films made
in hollywood anymore it's just nothing
but garbage
and so you expect that you expect a lot
of you know you expect the story to be
terrible uh maybe expect bad acting bad
script writing and everything else but
the one thing you would expect is that
at least the special effects should be
really
amazing by now
okay because the progress of history
there's it's not going to lead to
better storytelling
with the trajectory that we're on right
now but it should lead as technology
improves you'd think at least the
special effects will get better and they
haven't
and i think part of that is it's just
pure laziness on the part of the studios
they realize that they don't need to put
any effort really into the special
effects because they can just shovel
this garbage out and people will eat it
why put
it does it takes more time costs more
money to have good special effects why
bother
they just put anything out and slap the
marvel label on it and a bunch of morons
will just go watch it doesn't matter
put no effort into it whatsoever like
they are advertising to the audience we
do not care about this this is stupid
we put no effort into this
here you go and the audience goes oh gee
i can't wait to watch
meanwhile they're ignoring the aliens
so it makes it all the worse
let's get out to the comment section
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
old schooled says the daily wire really
needs to send matt walsh to the to the
white house as a reporter to participate
in the daily questions at the press
briefings well i would love that of
course but they have to give you
credentials and there's just no way
on god's green earth that they would
ever credential
me or the daily wires that's just not
ever going to happen
unknown sender says do an episode on the
last and the new doctor who in the
sci-fi series i'm confused what doctor
who is do you mean to leave this comment
on a different show you think i'm going
to talk about doctor who
were you
having a stroke or something when you
sent this comment i don't understand
talcum says why does he always say god
speed at the end i'm sitting on my ass
watching a video not going anywhere are
all his viewers supposed to be on the
start of some kind of journey i don't
get it yes
talcum every day is a journey we were
all on a journey together in the sweet
baby gang that's why i say it
um
let's see brandon says it brings joy to
my heart that matt's producers keep
putting the word tush in the rock auto
ads
yeah it's devious too because they know
that i'm like i'm
ron burgundy on the teleprompter i'll
read whatever they put in there and so
it's it's really not fair to me
uh bert mustin says the sue or lakota
are hated by other indian tribes in fact
the uh
ojibwa gave their name
gave them their name sue which means
little snake
well this is
in in general you know there was of
course warring and feuding and hatred
between indian tribes which is
one of the reasons why
even referring to kind of like
native americans as one homogenous
culture
lumping them all together just doesn't
make a lot of sense
they
would not have seen themselves that way
like
one indian tribe didn't see itself as
being in the same kind of category or
some sort of group with other indian
tribes
they were warring with each other and
killing each other they were feuding
over land and everything else
um daniel says
dude do you purposely say indians when
you should say native americans that's
pretty slimy man
yes i purposefully use the words that i
use that's true
and i don't say them accidentally
and you say i should say native american
who says that i mean who decided that i
should say that what do you mean i
should say
this is the term that i should be using
according to who
so i just don't i don't recognize those
rules
i understand that the pc police every
few years they change the the names that
you're supposed to use for certain
groups i just don't i don't recognize
that that's the issue daniel
i don't recognize their authority
i don't see that they have any authority
so i'll just use whatever words
i want to use
um and anyway it's not it's not any more
technically accurate to say native
american instead of indian
because well after all they weren't
americans before america existed as a
nation
okay there were no americans as we
as we used the term today until the
united states of america existed as a as
a nation
and so in that sense it doesn't really
you know tribes that were there
hundreds of years before the settlers
even showed up to call them americans
that's anachronistic also and not
exactly accurate
so i'm just going to use uh i think that
i think the term indian is fine it's
what has been used for for centuries and
everyone knows what i mean when i say it
so it's perfectly fine and i'll just say
it because that's what i feel like
saying
but thank you for giving me a chance to
clarify
well long last my sweet sweet babies the
next installment of my patch program has
arrived which you are welcome to go by
as long as you care enough about aliens
in which case you're not welcome to buy
this but if you do then it's the he him
wallrucks patch which is here to affirm
your identity and help project the
warped self-absorbed version of reality
in your mind on to everybody else which
is what it's all about you could secure
your piece of the collection and you'll
also receive a matching digital badge on
the daily wire platform upon purchase
remember these patches are limited
edition so don't miss out on your chance
to become one
of the chosen few that prove their
undying loyalty to the sweet baby gang
head over to my swag shack as we call it
at dailywire.com shop today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
it tells you something about the sorry
state of sports media that when i read
the following headline to you it will
not be immediately obvious which outlet
published it the headline is as follows
white fans were entertained by black
athletes a day after a racist killed
black people in buffalo
this is what white supremacy looks like
now the problem of course is that
literally any sports media outlet is
capable of inflicting something this
outrageously stupid on to the public
espn sports illustrated fox sports i
mean any of them could have done it
the sports media industry in this
country now sits somewhere to the left
of karl marx
and the average sports analyst sits
somewhere below a cantaloupe on the iq
scale and it's a quite a potent
combination to be to be sure
that's especially the case with the
author of this piece karen phillips or
karan phillips a race hustling vulture
so opportunistic stupid and shameless
that al sharpton reads his stuff it goes
whoa take it easy man that's a little
too far and though this article could
have appeared in any sports media outfit
it happens to have been published by
deadspin a company that i think first
got its name by combining the phrases
brain dead and political spin deadspin i
assume that's the etymology anyway it's
probably not necessary to actually read
any of this article
kind of like when you walk by a dumpster
on a hot day and you smell the putrid
garbage festering inside you don't need
to actually peek inside you kind of get
the gist
but we'll peek inside anyway um we know
we'll find smoldering trash but maybe
there will be a few surprises there for
us
let's find out phillips writes quote
sports only serve as an escape from
society if you're white
i have to stop there um
and we're only past the first sentence
but what do you mean escape from society
sports are happening within society
i've never heard anyone say man i need
to escape society for for for a little
while and then they turn on a basketball
game that's the kind of thing you say
before you turn your phone off and hike
into the woods or something
but we're only uh one sentence into this
thing we can't pick apart every
incoherence statement or else we'll be
here all day so let's continue
a long time ago in 2020 this country was
in the midst of what white america
deemed a racial awakening the fact that
they called it that was all the proof
anyone needed to realize that it was
less of an awakening and more of an
oxymoron
but yet here we are three years post
that awakening and everything is back to
business as if nancy pelosi taking a
knee in kente cloth and all these dei
workshops that were held at your job
magically fixed hundreds of years of
racism and if you don't believe me both
of sunday's game sevens were proof that
the awakening was only a brief moment of
pseudo-accountability that has passed
now skipping ahead a little bit phillips
begins to lament that to him somehow
sports are still not politicized enough
he says quote
players aren't getting asked how they
feel about things outside of 94 feet
after games as much uh it's as if
basketball or whatever sport they play
is all that should matter to them
sideline reporters aren't asking them
about roe v wade or if their loved ones
are scared to go to the grocery store
like they used to
wait i thought men aren't supposed to
have opinions about abortion
now you're mad that nba players
aren't giving their opinions about roe v
wade all right i forgot nothing you
people say means anything there are no
consistent principles in your world and
everything is relative which is why when
a leftist says that men should speak
about abortion what they really mean is
that men who disagree with them
shouldn't speak about abortion the
assumption probably correct is that most
nba players would take the pro-baby
killing side of the abortion debate in
which case their voices are welcome in
the discussion
which is not really supposed to be a
discussion but more of a chorus of
everybody saying exactly the same thing
but we still haven't gotten to what is
ostensibly supposed to be the subject of
this article after rambling a bit more
phillips finally gets around to
mentioning the mass shooting in buffalo
over the weekend and then he says this
on sunday
four teams played in two game sevens the
milwaukee bucks and boston celtics were
up first followed by the phoenix suns
and dallas mavericks three of the four
head coaches are black along with the
overwhelming majority of those team's
rosters however in boston where one of
the games was played over 52 percent of
the population is white according to the
latest census and in phoenix where the
suns were the host over 68 of the
residents are white what does this mean
well it means absolutely nothing but
go ahead
it means that a day after the after
black america was shaken to its core
because we've now realized that a
grocery store on our side of town has
become the latest place where we can be
killed just for existing black players
from the celtics bucks sons and
mavericks had to play in a win or go
home game to advance to the conference
finals despite the feelings that all of
us were experiencing and yet no one
seemed to care or asked them about it it
was clear that basketball mattered but
not black lives or the black psyche so
much
okay i get it now
well not really but what he's apparently
trying to say is that it was
dehumanizing to force black athletes to
play basketball a day after a mass
shooting
never mind that they were not forced and
that they were paid millions of dollars
for their troubles and that the thesis
here is that it's supposed to be uh like
that white supremacy
is is is why white people are watching
black athletes play sports
a claim he never even attempts to
explain or justify and which is
ludicrous on its face for about a dozen
reasons not the least of which being the
fact that white people pay lots of money
for the privilege of watching these
black athletes play and those black
athletes profit immensely from the
exchange and it's an exchange that all
parties concerned are voluntarily
participating in
anyway finally phillips wraps things up
this way he says
so many times in just the last few years
there have been nerve-wracking incidents
that have left black america even more
paranoid than we've always been and
while everybody else gets to move on
we're still left dealing with the trauma
despite how it might not always show out
itself on the outside we never get to
fully exhale and let go because when
you're a black athlete in america
competing at the highest level as a form
of entertainment for the rest of the
world
all the while knowing that the majority
of the people that cheer for you don't
think your life matters
maybe the hardest part of the game that
you work at that a reporter will never
ask about
wait a second quick let's just go back
down i don't even understand that last
sentence wait just scroll down a little
bit okay
the people that cheer for you don't
think your life matters maybe the
hardest part of the game that you work
at that a reporter will never ask about
okay
so quran phillips sees the phantasm of
systemic racism everywhere yet hasn't
noticed that he managed to
get a job as a writer when he's barely
able to put together intelligible
sentences
that kind of like disconfirms the
systemic racism theory in and of itself
also needless to say
phillips did not write a similar piece
lamenting the fact that white athletes
had to play a day at had to play you
know in their sports a day after the
waukesha massacre
indeed more white people are killed by
black people than the reverse in this
country
but this is a fact that doesn't factor
into quran's analysis
no facts
factor into his analysis this article is
not so much an analysis as a rambling
schizophrenic screed composed by a
raging narcissist whose head is so
firmly implanted up his own rear end
that he manages to see himself and a
bunch of millionaire athletes as the
victims of a violent crime for which
none of them were anywhere within the
vicinity
and here's the most crucial point okay
a white racist killed black people in
buffalo
everyone of course agrees that it was a
horrific evil crime
if i had my way the culprit would be
swiftly and publicly executed
quran phillips says he's afraid of
something similar happening to him can't
even go out in public without worrying
about it he says well
he should be
relieved then to be informed that
violent murderous attacks against black
people by white people
are thankfully extraordinarily rare
according to fbi statistics there are
about 3 000 white murder victims every
year and about 3 000 black murder
victims a little more a little the white
murder victims are there's a little bit
more there but you know giver takes
around 3 000. these numbers have gone up
during the crime surge over the past two
years but i'm talking about the average
over the past you know decade or two
now in the case of both the white and
black murder victims the vast majority
from both categories are killed by
members of their own race
um but about five to six hundred of the
white victims are killed by black people
while about two to three hundred of the
black victims are killed by whites
given that there are significantly fewer
black people in the country than white
that means that statistically speaking a
black person is exponentially more
likely to kill a white person than the
reverse that's the simple statistical
fact of the matter
it cannot be disputed the data says what
the data says
does this invalidate quran phillips's
claim
that black americans do or should have
some special unique fear of racially
motivated violence
yes it doesn't validate it
completely and utterly
but the real point here
is not that more black people kill white
people than reverse because even though
that's rare even though it's true it's
still very rare
the real point is that almost all of the
murder is you know in-house racially
speaking
which means that
if black people on a day-to-day basis
are fearful of becoming victims of
violence
and in many communities they have
certainly have reason to be in fear of
that
it's not white people who are causing
that fear
the fact is that black people are indeed
killed every single day in this country
while simply living their lives that is
true
it's happening
a lot
it's an enormous problem
enormous
but people like quran phillips ignore
almost all of that violence almost all
of it
say nothing about it ever
thousands and thousands and thousands of
black victims of violence completely
ignored
crime phillips doesn't care about them
he has nothing to say about them
he waits for the rare murder that serves
his political purposes
and there aren't many that serve his
purposes
but when they happen that's when he
speaks
and then he pretends to give a damn
about anyone other than himself
it's a charade
and it's not at all convincing
and that's why he is today
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode
democrats push controversial new
domestic terrorism laws following the
buffalo mass shooting the house
intelligence committee holds a public
hearing on ufos and a key trial stemming
from the durham investigation begins
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morningwire